day two of Bill Cosby's sexual assault
trial begins this morning over the
coming days a prosecution will call
accuser Andrea constant and her mother
Gianna to the stand
Bill Cosby's defense team attacked
andrea constand's character on the first
day of the trial yesterday
the prosecution accused the actor
comedian of using Fame and power to take
advantage of trusting young women
DeMarco Morgan is outside the Montgomery
County Courthouse in Norristown
Pennsylvania DeMarco good morning good
morning Gail on the first day of Court
vote Cosby's defense team argued that
Andrea constant repeatedly lied about
her relationship with Cosby and her
alleged sexual assault the prosecution
said constant was betrayed by someone
she thought was a mentor and asked the
jury to push aside his larger-than-life
celebrity persona and see him for who
they say he really is Bill Cosby left in
Montgomery County Courthouse Monday
night after nearly 10 hours of opening
arguments and testimony earlier in the
day Cosby smiled as actress keshia
knight pulliam who played its daughter
Rudy Huxtable on The Cosby Show
accompanied him to court I came to
support because this is where you hear
the facts this is where
Bin's Cosby's defense team targeted
Andrea Constance credibility they
contradicted her initial claim that she
didn't contact cosmic after the alleged
2004 sexual assault
they said Cosby and Constance spoke by
phone 72 times and that constant
initiated 53 of the calls the
prosecution argued that constant tried
to maintain a sense of normalcy after
the alleged incident and said the case
is about trust betrayal and the
inability to consent they both made very
strong points attorney Dennis McAndrews
was at the court the prosecution was a
more clinical event by event approach
and the defense approach was much more
animated and aggressive Kelly Johnson
prosecution's first witness cried on the
stand she claims Cosby drugged her with
a white fill and made her touches
private parts in 1996 during
cross-examination the defense cited a
deposition Johnson gave where she said
the alleged incident happened in 1990
not 1996 this jury had a real poker face
I think they're taking to judges
instructions to heart that you don't
decide this case until it's over now
Johnson is the only Cosby accuser
allowed to testify besides constant now
at the start of the trial of the judge
told the jury it is their job to find
the facts he taught him not to be bogged
down by taking notes and to carefully
listen to witness testimonies Charlie
DeMarco thanks